warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is
advised what happened at a certain
moment we went on Sabbath to the church
uh we took uh her up uh by car but she
said I I can't come along because I had
a very nasty experience uh last uh night
she the experience was that she uh she
wanted to to commit suicide and she did
a long walk to the uh station uh to to
to the train uh where the train run MH
and at a certain moment there was a uh
sort of black figure behind her M and
the black figure said to her I know
where you're going
M hello everybody Welcome to an LED live
we have some awesome guests from the
Netherlands as you can tell a wonderful
picture of the Netherlands right here
and uh I had an opportunity to visit
over this summer was I no winter I was
there in the winter wi January yeah
January and um meth these guys got a
chance to speak at one of their Church's
um initiatives where they were doing a
little Outreach and uh it was awesome
and they have a very unique story that
you guys won't want to miss um something
happened in their experience and all of
a sudden Supernatural things started
happening in their family so we're going
to get into this but Welcome to our show
guys thank you thank you so tell me a
little bit about your background so that
our audience can understand like were
you raised in Christianity like um you
know early on in your childhood or your
lives like did your parents go to
church yeah we were we were uh um I was
a Christian uh I was a Dutch reformed
Christian it's was in Dutch it's d word
MH and uh we were we tradition
[Music]
traditional Christians and so so we went
uh always on Sunday to the church and uh
in in the beginning when it was young
twice there Sunday on to the church and
later on it was when I was older and so
Grew Older was maybe once once in the
church but I always wanted to go to the
church myself um you were interested in
spiritual things I was interested Al all
always in spiritual things mhm so but
the experience of uh of of my experience
uh now is quite different from the exper
on on Sabbath is quite different from
the experience that we had on Sunday
always mhm were you were you a a Bible
student I mean did you read the Bible a
lot were you familiar with a lot of the
Bible Concepts and text school on the
school we got all all the all all the
stories of course so we were a customer
with this uh with the stories and all so
that that was this was familiar for for
us old uh Testament New Testament so
that was all well known for for for me
mhm uh but but yeah but but not in the
way it is now it is totally different
interesting in what way how would you
describe that uh when I met him um I was
I was not as uh uh going to church as as
y did but um well I was B baptized when
I uh was uh
30 and uh and and together with my my
daughter she was baptized then too
because I we she was born then and you
know that in the Sunday churches most
Sunday churches they baptize as baby
babies is by uh oh sprinkling sprinkling
oh so that's what you did when you were
baptized it was a not an immersion oh no
okay okay
interesting um and uh well together with
my eldest daughter mhm and um and that
was it and uh I later I became I was an
elder and uh all different things well
we we we did all the things in in
Christianity it it was for that uh
belief it was good mhm but it was
totally different when we became
Adventist yeah so church was a regular
part of your guys's upbringing and your
family as you began in a new family and
so you know what what began to make the
change the change I think to to our new
life so to say uh became from our oldest
daughter okay and uh we had some
experiences with her from her youth on
mhm when she was a baby already mhm uh
we had some some strange things like
what can you describe any of them when
she was little when she was uh 6 years
old um she had already things she saw in
in her bedroom and uh things as in
spirits Spirits she could actually
physically see the spirits yeah wow she
saw it like it were human yeah but they
were all in in in in uh clothes was
totally um ragged ragged and and and
they they they bled on bled on their
faces and so on it was very scary
interesting almost as if they're trying
to cause fear yeah she was also she was
always uh feared by by that yeah I I can
go back to when she was a baby already
she'd cry uh she cried and she uh uh
fored a lot the milk and so and then my
wife V didn't know what to do about that
and then we had a sort of a friend of us
said there is a person there outside who
can help you with a photo when you send
a photo of of an Mar and that's my
daughter called um then she can read in
a photo what what is the solution for
that so so this person is like a medium
sort of sort of medium s of a medium but
we didn't recognize it then I've never
even heard of anything like this like
you can actually send a photo they look
at a photo tell what's wrong with send
it by by mail a photo to to that lady it
was far away from us okay so uh we sent
it and we got a message back called her
back she called back and she said uh
okay you have to do this and this and
what what do you guess it was a solution
or not yeah no no it it was a very good
solution oh okay it was yes but because
it worked because because she said the
things that worked what did she say to
do what specifically do I don't not
specific
she gave some some medicine not not not
like an oil or a tinure or something
like that yeah yeah tinctures yeah yeah
yeah and so she said if you use these
they then it will will go better and and
it was and it did resolve it so what did
that do to your belief then at that
point uh to our Christian believe not
not so much we didn't we didn't think
about it we didn't thought about it
because because scientifically you
cannot prove that yeah right so so it's
a sort of uh things that happen if you
don't know anything about that it's for
for us was it was a mystery it was very
good that she did this is how the devil
often works right he he he will I mean
he's working in almost the same way of
Jesus like think about what Jesus is
doing right he's resolving a problem
Jesus healed more times than he actually
preached in the Bible right he was that
was his first way of getting in the door
and I bet you the devil's looking at
that going hm I can cause a problem over
here then I can give you a solution for
it and you're going to listen yeah so
you open the door to the occult you open
the door to the occult unknowingly
because you don't know and
people Mo a lot of people are opening
the door for this kind of thing not
knowingly people are not stupid people
people are misled by these kind of uh
happening so she did not probably see as
a baby these things until that door was
opened or do you think she was
experiencing those well before that we
don't know we don't know yeah of course
you can't talk to the baby but later on
she said that she experienced things
when she was very very
little uh what she couldn't know so they
would talk to her yeah well she she saw
things interesting and and she knew also
later on that she saw that when she was
very little interesting as as a baby uh
already and uh for example she saw saw
rabbits running through through the the
wall and running out of the wall wow in
a sleeping room and so she and it were
rabbits were not not those skin rabbits
so sweet things but uh like scary
looking rabbits you know there's a lot
of movies there was a movie called
Donnie Darko that they made where his
outfit was this Twisted
rabbit in occult kind of dark satanic
movies they're often using the rabbit
and I wonder why I mean we know Alison
Wonderland right follow the White Rabbit
you know and and there's a lot of
references to rabbits as a child I'm
sure she was not exposed to those things
so that's that's very
fascinating interesting yeah so did that
scare you guys as parents I mean your
daughter's telling you she's seen weird
things walk through the walls I mean
what are you guys thinking of that it
was later on that she she she told us
that it was not at that moment he was
not 6y old because uh then uh she
thought well everyone will will see
something like that yeah she thought it
was normal it was normal yes wow the the
big problem started more or less when
she was 11 years she she had always uh a
pain in her stomach in her uh and and
how do you say abdomen mhm abdomen
abdomen and uh she had always pain there
and then I uh I went to uh the doctor
also in
hospital and uh well there was nothing
uh they could see where where where came
fine it was fine yes and um then um I
ALS also said to this doctor yes also
she she she sees um something in her
room and then the doctor told me that uh
well it can be because when she's asleep
then she can see something in her sleep
but I said no she was awake oh oh well
it can also it's also possible when you
are
sleeping and then get uh awake then you
also can see the dream you had and your
mind kind ofing on with what it was
processing but I said well it was not
something like that he was already Wide
Awake Wide Awake yes yeah but they have
no answer on it I mean this I think it's
absolutely crazy we we have two movies
that have that have come out recently
within the last year one is called if
it's about an imaginary friend that's
why they got the I and the F the if and
and it's about kids seen things Spirits
basically I mean they they call them
imaginary friends or whatever like this
and as they grow older then they don't
want those things anymore and they don't
see them anymore but that's a scary
thing for a kid I mean I can only
imagine like you know disrupting your
sleep all those things and then adding
on top of that
pain you as a parent you just want to
resolve the problem and then then was
the next step it was there was were
doctors who were what you talked about
and then it was so so bad uh at that
time that we went to the hospital with
her okay she was there for a week I
think or something and she didn't dare
to go alone to the hospital so you were
vit was uh there beside her mhm and
strange things happened there because an
America yeah uh saw all all kinds of
stuff Hospital in the hospital wow so
she could for example when when we uh
when your parents arrived for example
she could see outside who arrived oh wow
without seeing them uh because she was
in her bed and and yeah so is her body
taken like sort of like out in in person
to the front
and her spirit or something like that or
demons they call this astral projection
such as this and she could so see what
what was happening at that moment
what what was happening outside now I
really wonder why does the Demonic world
give this kind of ability to to people
what are they trying to achieve by that
I mean obviously make fear and then
hopefully she will Embrace that side and
think she has some special gift or
something but yeah also that that
because she has such a special gifts she
she could see things we were on our way
to Holiday and we have also special
presents mhm and we give them away so
and they have to cast a number mhm and
uh 1 to 10 mhm and then when you have
the right number you get the present so
and Anica always had number this no and
we said to an you you don't participate
you because you know it oh yeah yeah wow
so so if I were you and I was the parent
and my kid had that we we'd go straight
to the lottery I'm
kidding like we're going on a field trip
today yeah yeah but I mean like what a
crazy thing so you actually told her she
can't play because yeah you you don't
you don't guess only the other two
that's amazing yes now as Christian
Christianity is is sort of in your
background what are you thinking
spiritually at this point because you're
in a church that believes in like what
when you die your spirit just goes to
heaven so are you thinking okay there's
spirits around and they're floating
around and they can start communica our
process is not not at all at that stage
at that moment because we were at the
hospital with her and the hospital
didn't have a solution so we took her
back home and uh later on she had to go
again in the hospital and her her
appending was removed because it was so
very bad uh that we uh would to do
everything anything we we were
completely desperate so they took out
the panics and after a week nothing
happened so it was the same uh wow she
still has has the the the pain it was
still
today then no no no today the after it
wasn't the appendic it was it was that
um it was the the the fear I think and
the fear can wow man itself so bad that
that the her whole body was uh full of
uh responding to it you know there's a
book that was written that was talking
about diseases and things that that um
we have and some of the emotions that
we're into like basically let's say
we're angry right that will manifest
itself inside of our bodies in a certain
way and it was a very interesting
concept that that um you know kind of
fear causes something like that and it
can definitely mess with your biology of
your body so so in in that same period
She did go to school for 3 months or so
I think wow and in that 3 months he
couldn't walk wow so and she was bad
ritten uh no yeah she was bedridden uh
she she walked and I have to we had to
support her to toilet and yeah yeah oh
wow so once I was at home maybe I can
tell the story MH uh once I was at home
she had to go to the toilet I I brought
her so to the toilet otherwise she would
fall the back and she came back and she
said there and they are in the here in
the in the room wow so they try they try
to kill me and uh I said no they cannot
kill you because I'm here with you right
so I talked to them wow the spears then
did they talk to about you back no by my
daughter okay and uh I said you they
cannot do uh uh anything to you and then
an said okay they are now telling me
that uh you don't have any power for
there so you cannot protect me so that
is quite scary of course oh yeah and uh
then we we had the custom she uh of
putting candles because where where a
lit candle is the demon does not appear
oh wow so she saw
there sort of spirit Y and I put a
candle there and she then she saw that
and I put a candle there oh wow so and
that at the moment she came back
and I supported her mhm yeah and uh at
one moment she turned herself around and
fell with her hair to the back in in the
candle oh wow like something pulled her
down something pulled her down so I
could I could support her at the right
moment but that was very scary for me oh
yeah uh the talking was very scary oh
yeah but also uh that I had to talking
meaning you it was talking to her and
she's relaying what it's saying yes I
think I would just like pass out I think
it's actually a blessing that we don't
see the spiritual warfare around us I
think it would absolutely freak all of
us out yeah yeah yeah so this uh
absolutely amazing one of the things and
was also one time that
um uh she was I we were already asleep
and then I heard something in from her
bedroom noise and uh when I came there
then she stood in the window and she
said the whole room was burning but uh
there was no no fire so it it was in her
imagine or the there yes the the the
demons were she was awake showing
showing it to her something like that
and uh I had to uh take her off of the
the the window and uh otherwise she
would have jumed jumped wow we don't
know what will happen then so did they
constantly encourage her to end her life
or they so they they she had also always
the feeling that she wanted to die be I
mean as a kid if you've grown up seen
these things all the time it's like
there's a point where you're just like I
don't care I don't want to deal with
this anymore I understand that yes she
was always afraid always afraid she
could can't go to sleep at night she
couldn't no because always uh when when
she was um um little she wants to to be
with us and uh was always scared at a
certain moment he slept beside her or
from from her and would they leave her
alone when you when she was in your
space uh yes for the most part yes for
the most part they didn't follow her in
there and keep talking to her or
whatever um later on yes but first not
oh W then uh well she grew up yeah of
course and she couldn't do when is not
yeah she's an adult like a little weird
if she's crawling into bed with you but
yeah so she just had to basically deal
with it yes when when she was 27 and she
was free but before that we are not
talking she was 11 years so she had it
from a childhood all the way to 27 and
then it stopped mhm What stopped it yeah
but but you're not there yet after that
we uh had no solution and we went to
another hospital in far from us away
okay and we had also experiences there
about her and so um in the hospital she
sees them walking around in the halls
and things okay so I have to tell this
story I I was um preaching in Florida
one time and uh a lady that was uh had
invited us she had told me a little bit
about um her experience she had she had
grown up in and and gotten involved in
Wiccan and she said her group
specifically um prayed over the
hospitals and that the demons would have
power at the hospital because God is
very merciful and at the hospital
there's a lot of spiritual warfare
that's happening as people are on their
deathbed God is so patient and and so
loving I mean think about the thief on
the cross he'd take them on their dying
breath and so they were praying that the
demonic spirits would not let God's
angels or for his side basically win
that Soul before they died that's why
it's really important to pray for people
in the hospital because was always
protected uh in some way she never did
she tried maybe to to do bad things to
herself but she was always protected at
uh wow some strange measure that she she
was away in in the middle of the night
and then she was uh afraid and uh she
called us some out that story you know
that uh still but then we were already
Adventist oh yeah then we were already
Adventist but uh yeah because we we can
go further we uh in 2001 my mother died
and uh before that um we had uh uh my my
parents uh had a conversation with uh my
father's brother and and my my
cousin and uh they uh they told about us
and then they said they were
atst and uh they said uh to to my father
and mother that um well what they are
doing is not good and um you um you you
I will give you a
book and uh when you read it then uh you
know what what they are what they are
doing wrong and so uh my mother gave me
the book of uh Roger Mano oh wow the
trip into the supernatural yeah love
that book and we uh I uh I read it mhm
and then I I thought yes uh we have to
do it different wow so just so our
audience um knows Roger mono a book
called a trip into the Supernatural is
quite amazing it is about a demon
worshipper he became part of a cult and
joined up in Canada I believe and I mean
he met talked with had some crazy super
natural experiences and then came out of
that on God's side and forever for the
rest of his life the demons messed with
him and um you know when he gave his
heart fully back to God they weren't
allowed to come you know very close but
he he would recognize he'd walk down the
street and they would kick cans over and
throw things and try to scare him
constantly and and um but um amazing he
got away this was a step for to to in
our faith uh uh really uh so I would
encourage everyone to read uh the book
of Roger mono yeah because it give you a
great light into the spiritual world
yeah if everybody should read that book
or or or see the video yeah you always
also have the video recorded at our
website Li Channel tv.org awesome is it
in English or Dutch it's uh in English
subtitled by Dutch oh I love it okay so
we'll put a link to that video in the
description but um okay awesome so
you've get you've got r maro's book now
you're starting to question what are we
doing we're doing something before
before that we went to uh a woman and it
was uh they because uh she all she she
still had those experiences with the
demons and so on and she uh couldn't
live her life and uh then someone said
to us well you have to uh go to to that
woman and it was uh 22
50 Kil kilometers from our home so uh
well it was every h two times a week we
went to this lady and uh she still did
this did those uh uh wicked things MH
but we later on we we we knew that it
was wicked but then we didn't know MH so
and later on we we we saw that she was a
a witch oh wow but then well we are we
ask also uh them are you Christian and
so on and they said yeah yeah isn't that
funny there there is a real thing that
people say they're Christian witches
yeah and it's just like wow people say
that they're
white black witches they are white
Angels Black Angels it doesn't make any
sense no you're on God's side or you're
on the devil's side yes so yeah but but
but when you later on you you think well
you you could have known it because when
you went on onto the the at the stairs
you saw all kinds of uh pictures of uh
Indians Indians of those you know the
the head of the Indians and the natives
and maybe she was a shaman you you can
say it also in English Shaman Shaman mhm
that she was that's like a witch doctor
or a I don't know what you call a priest
or whatever in the dark arts oh wow okay
and once we were there when there was a
full moon okay and uh we we came there
and purposely or accidentally no
accidentally we we were there but then
she said to us oh you cannot come
because it is full moon and and we
thought well what is the head who cares
about that yeah right right and and did
she give you a reason like no no but lat
on we knew of course because full moon
we know that they are doing some ritual
of course so you know I don't fully
understand what goes on in the occult
but but um the way I've described it it
or I've heard it described especially
like in the cabala and and some of these
like really dark mystical Arts is
there's like Circles of um sort of where
these demons can reside and and interact
and at certain times of the year those
circles cross over into other circles
and they're able to interact in a
different way than they normally do and
so that's why they follow the cycle of
the Moon and stuff like this and
whatever I have no I don't think I I
have no idea or understanding about that
but it's very interesting that they that
they somehow they respect those those
times of the year and or those times of
the month and and that gives them
greater access to coming out and
interacting with Humanity I don't know
but we had not any idea about that they
were witches or something like that at
that moment not but later on you you you
saw it but uh so so you've you've been
getting involved in this your daughter's
still dealing with this and then where's
the kind of turning point where you
starting to like go off in the in better
Direction well we also experienced that
uh the the that woman could heal her a
little bit because she had less uh that
less demons were in her bedroom and so
on and uh but uh our daughter didn't
like it to go there at at all she was
she didn't uh want to to go because she
experienced not good things
there but uh when uh when I uh I got
I've got that book of uh Roger Mano I
said to my husband to Johan that um well
we cannot go there anymore and uh I I I
called her and I said well we quit and
she said to me oh no you must not quit
because then she becomes uh uh
worse again and then I have to heal her
again and I have to uh no do that's how
the devil works right I'll just take
away my own people so you think it's
helping you but if you stop I'm going to
send more yeah and then uh we prayed and
we prayed and we said to God well we
need a church uh who is helping us with
this and then uh then we were at that
church still at the old church still at
the at the old church church and then my
mother died and uh she always lived as
an
Adventist uh not always but my
grandmother is an Adventist and she uh
did you know about that as a as a young
child or even in your early part of
marriage or was that well we knew you
knew what it was yeah okay well not not
not not all all the things of course but
we know we knew that they are they
Sabbath Keepers they eat vegetarian
food no no not all over the world
okay they they didn't do it in Dutch
culture that's off the table right no
yeah for some but yeah yeah there you go
so so uh and then uh my father wants to
do the the funeral uh of her uh and he
he asked well in the surroundings to if
pastors could do the the the funeral and
then um they couldn't do it and then we
asked our pastors of our church
uh uh if they could do it but they
wanted to but they had no time at that
moment three pastors couldn't come and
and then my father thought well she she
held she kept the Sabbath and so on and
uh well maybe uh my uh my uh cousin knew
some someone who could do the the
funeral and then she came up with a
pastor uh Adventist pastor and he
immediately said yes and then um well he
did it and then we came in contact with
this this pastor and we ask him also to
to help us with those things we we uh we
we are troubled with it so and did he
did he did he readily say yeah sure I
can I can try to help with that that's
good I think there's well that is not
the case Okay so not not exactly but he
he gave us Bible study okay good so he
he's at least kind of like you know okay
well I don't know about that but I'll
help you with with some spiritual
understanding the the experience that we
had uh with our daughter were not well
known to him yes so that he it was a far
away uh from my bed show so so but but
yeah but we are very glad to get Bible
studies this is exactly why I wanted to
talk about this subject right here not a
lot of people talk about this not a lot
of people understand what to do with
this no and and I think more people
probably experience this than we would
like to admit but but they don't they
don't know nothing about it that's right
that's right uh almost none none in our
church know know know anything about
that there is very few people that speak
on the subject we've had a couple guests
on our show that talked about
deliverance and and how to cast out
demons and things like that and and um I
mean but but casting out demons is also
uh you you need to do it in a special
way this is correct and and not in
casting out demons and you ready with it
right so so does it doesn't work like
that way the only way that we became
Adventist was because of this point
interesting not because of Sabbath or
not because of other things the only
thing is like we'll try
this we spoke to the devil to to the
demons to the spirits and so we didn't
spoke we didn't speak no but we didn't
speak to them it's maybe but we we did
the wrong things in our lives with this
kind of stuff we you open the door yeah
we opened the door and we should have
stopped it
immediately and uh but you kept kind of
going to trying to figure out a solution
for this and that may be worsen the
because the regular medicine couldn't
help us right right and we were
desperate right we were desperate right
and uh yeah wow cuz now at this point
you've had other children yeah and your
other children do not experience these
things no none of them even yeah so it's
not necessarily that you know just
because you did this now your whole
family's being tormented it was
specifically dealing with one of your
children your firstborn yes yeah wow and
so what began to turn the
corner what was the Turning Point well
you started having Bible studies with
this pastor well it wasn't 2001 and so
it it's it's already 23 years ago when
when we experienced all these and uh we
had uh Bible
studies together with my father mhm and
uh the three of us we were baptized in
2005 wow and um well we had also four
years Bible cud yeah this time fully
emerged yeah yes not sprinkled no no
fully immersed underwater de and under
yeah and then we um we wanted to to have
uh prayer
meetings because there was well not the
use of uh they are not used to to do
prayer meetings there in that church and
we asked for them for U well to pray and
to pray for all the peop of court but
also for our our
daughter but she was already then she
was uh 12 I think
13 and um she had to make her own
experience she couldn't uh be uh through
us to to to get
uh uh well how you say be freed from the
the demons she had had her own
experience MH and then um yes it was
still uh our our um what do you say our
bapti baptism was not
uh uh affecting her that she was freed
of of her demons right this is your walk
but she's still dealing with some of
these things yeah okay and uh and and
also we of course because uh yeah we uh
we went on with the prayer meetings uh
all along way through and we kept
praying for for the daughter and we
always when we when we met met people we
always talked about it to hope that they
would pray for for her of course more
power in the prayer power in the prayer
get more people on this thing you know
for sure and and uh that was very
important for us and it was also
important for us to um well we were we
were also acquainted with uh world of
white the videos of we had him on our
show loved it total Onslaught awesome
Yep total Onslaught big big impact on me
we were so impressed by it and uh we
wanted to that the the whole world would
would hear his message and uh we were
very excited of it and uh we wanted to
to share this also with our uh church
members and um well and also to do it
outside outside the church so we wanted
to to start our own Ministry awesome and
so the name of your ministry is light I
just love it because it's very similar
to little light we the little light
God's the greater light but you're
sharing light in the Netherlands yeah
wow you guys so so now Ana ma when when
she was 27 you mentioned this that she
began to start to find some relief from
this yeah when she was 277 she um at
first uh she was very uh tormented by by
the demons still still but then she was
already out of our house out our home
she she went by herself uh she was had a
little apartment somewhere where near to
where we
live and uh but then she was still uh
when we were on on holiday she she she
called us and she said oh I'm so
harassed by the demons uh could you pray
for me she asked me she asked us and uh
well we prayed and um she ALS she always
gets some Bible text in her head that
that God gives her and she said well it
was I think Psalm uh Psalm uh 13 13 13
and it talks about that you know we have
had on our show like I said um um some
people talking about this spiritual
warfare especially centering around
demonic um um annoyance and things like
that they always say that the prayers
the um the Bible texts specifically the
promises and singing those three things
are the best way to to they don't like
that and I can imagine why the Demonic
world would not like singing maybe
because they realize and they hear these
songs it reminds them of heaven then it
reminds them of how far they've fallen
or something like this they just don't
like it and they're just like nah I
don't want to hear this and and and and
they'll go away they hate the name of
Jesus you know and and those things so
Bible texts you guys if you are
experiencing any kind of demonic like
oppression or they're starting to speak
to you or whatever like this take a note
from some experiences that have have
have dealt with this kind of a thing go
read the Psalms there's a lot of
promises in the Psalms and and
specifically the ones where God is your
strength God if you abide in the shadow
of the almighty you know he will protect
you and and you you you use that
spiritual warfare by wielding the word
of God it's exactly what Jesus did when
Satan came to tempt him he used thus it
is written right here it says this go
God had always uh always a protector
yeah and uh I I can recall uh something
what happened at a certain moment we
went on Sabbath to the church uh uh we
took uh her up uh by car but she said I
I can't come along because I had a very
nasty experience uh last night she the
experience was that she uh she wanted to
to commit suicide and she did a long
walk to the uh station uh to to the
train uh where the train run mhm and at
a certain moment there was a a sort of
black figure behind her M and the black
figure said to her
I know where you're going so and a black
man it was it was a black man I think
and uh she was very scared because there
was nobody in the surroundings there and
uh that man said I know what you were up
to uh so and he came closer and closer
and go around turn turn and go back to
your home wow and uh and Amer turned
back to home to all the other direction
wow and he he he walked some way with
her yeah he he walked together with her
and with her talked with her oh wow and
then she walked further and further and
at a certain moment she looked around
and he was not no one there oh
wow so that was I would love yeah but
that was very scary for her so do you
think that was her angel
yeah it was a a well it was a well how
to to come to the station uh of the
railways and then uh he he accompanied
her to to her almost to her her
apartment again to make sure she was
going back home yeah yeah and uh then
she would think her and him and uh well
and he he was walking away and then she
she turned around and then she didn't
see him anymore so it must be an angel
wow wow you know what what a scary but
what a what a beautiful experience like
that that that that we know that there
is God is not going to leave us alone I
mean we are constantly surrounded by I I
remember reading a story um um recently
we we we read these little bible stories
and stuff like that of of um different
uh angels and things that have happened
in in in people's experiences and there
was a guy who wanted to have a Bible
study and he had invited a bunch of
people and nobody showed up and he was
really sad about it but he was like you
know what God I said I was going to do a
Bible study and he and he prayed and
then God opened his eyes and he looked
around the room and he said there was
shoulder toh shoulder um giant angels
with she described their black hair and
beautiful like you know almost
iridescent looking clothing and things
like this standing back shoulder Tosh
shoulder in the entire room like there
was hundred of them you know and that
was God's way of just going you're not
alone you know yeah what a beautiful
experience but scary at the same time
that you but it was I think 2013
2012 that was not already her her
decision to uh to B to to commit suicide
no no yeah she wanted always still
commit suicide yeah and uh she didn't
want to to to give her life to Christ
really at that moment not yet not no wow
so that's even more amazing that your
angels there protecting you and you're
pushing away on them yeah so so often
she came home in her home she she lived
alone and then the doors were already
open oh wow and the all the gas was all
burning oh no in the room see those in
the kitchen in the kitchen in the
kitchen those kind of things are crazy
to me it's not an illusion it was real
she she had closed the door when she
went away and and it was completely open
she she also said always uh it doesn't
have a sense to to close the door
because they can come come in along way
yeah she's seen him going through the
walls yes yeah but but really opening
the door oh wow yeah not not seeing
through the walls this was really open
the door when she came home they also
also going through the wall yeah but
they all also she also experienced that
they were sleeping next to her and um it
was also very scary she then she she
heard them breathing and so on and uh
she always had done she makes that noise
with uh some radio or or something like
that and that she couldn't hear the the
the noise of them I remember when when
um I got a chance to talk to her a
little bit about it it was really
interesting how she described like cuz I
asked is there a physical form are you
seeing these things in its complete
entirety and she said not always it's
it's your eyes and she sometimes will
just see their eyes like red eyes in the
room and they're just watching you an
also yeah yeah and sometimes she saw
that red eyes into my eyes and then she
was scared about me oh interesting it
was also very scary for her yeah she
thought said she was the devil then
because then I I couldn't uh
comfort her anymore sure so it was very
it was a very scary time for her so
today how is she doing today she doing
now very good very good what was the
remedy that really well she was in
2013 she was baptized in June first June
gave her heart completely to God yes
awesome she gave her testimony also then
into in in the church and very many
people were very impressed by it yes and
uh when she's ready I want her to give
her testimony here I want to hear it
from her I've heard it from her
personally but I want her to share it
with the audience does DARE it she
doesn't dare it I know she is very
modest and and and um things like this
but I thank you guys for coming on and
being willing to talk about this but um
and and then she but then the the the
feeling of doing of committing suicide
was was still there yeah so she did not
really give her whole whole her heart to
Jesus mhm and that it was uh that she
had another experience to to do that so
uh when she did that then it was it was
gone yeah everything was gone so when
she fully committed and surrendered to
God yeah he took that away yeah he took
that away mhm oh let that be a lesson to
any of you guys out there if you're
experiencing this kind of stuff just you
know what if you want respit from this
if you want a remedy from this the
remedy is found in Jesus and if you
fully give yourself to him fully Lord
I'm Yours completely in and out clean
out house you know what I mean he did it
for the demoniac in the Bible he did it
many times and and we have experiences
in the Bible physical experiences in
today's world today he's the same
yesterday as he is today as he will be
tomorrow and he will deliver us but this
was still a big battle for her I bet we
talk about it very easily now but it was
a yes because very big battle she was
she uh when she was baptized she already
knew uh a guy who uh who wanted to marry
her and and she was first baptized and
then in December he was yeah December he
was baptized and and then later on on on
one year later he left her and uh at
that moment when um it was on uh the
31th of December she came home and she
said to
us
uh uh his her first husband said to her
I will not come again to you I will
leave you and then she had a thought
will I go with him and go to take the
life of him again M or and then the
voice of God told her when when do you
follow me and then she said yes Lord I
will follow you she uh completely
changed because she uh because of her
all her years of of of of uh pressure of
the Demons he was also um very uh became
sick and so on and she uh because of all
those stress and so on and then
uh uh she she got a relief wow and also
the the the the pressure of the or the
the demons she didn't see them anymore
wow you know what's crazy is when you
meet Anam Mar it's she's so sweet and
she's so gentle and I remember her
talking about these kind of things and
and that just it just didn't seemed like
what are you serious like like she seems
completely like calmed from it and you
know you don't see the anxiety that that
you're describing um so I praise God
that we serve a god of answered prayers
and sometimes you know it takes years
took a what a journey for you guys to go
through and have to experience but
praise God that you stuck with it you
tried different things now you're
involved in Ministry I think one of the
most amazing things that I got to
witness is your whole family's in
Ministry and if you guys don't know I
don't know if you want to talk about um
she got remarried yes she goes remarried
who' she get remarried to to Teo Hoffman
Teo we put Teemo on the show in fact um
here's a picture of Teo right here check
this out he had a awesome testimony of
how he came out of the whole Rock scene
and into this but this is teemo's wife
we're talking about here this is this is
teemo's in-laws right here and I just I
I love it that your whole family was
involved in Ministry it was really neat
for me to see when you were there they
were working behind the scenes making
that whole thing happen and you know in
the Netherlands you know this particular
faith is not large over there and so you
know I praise God that you guys are
really taking that that um baton and
really trying to reach your countrymen
with with these precious truths yes this
also because because we we knew we
experienced Satan in our family yeah and
we wanted to uh that also the people in
in in
Holland could see that and and yeah
could see what Jesus can do that's right
Jesus is the answer he's the power and
if we literally I love the the thing
that came out of this conversation was
if we submit to him yes submit 100% to
him 100% awesome you guys what a
beautiful story and I know it was kind
of uh rough and tough on you for many
years but praise God that you guys are
where you're at that your faith is
strong that your family is together that
you're you know you're still pressing
forward and sharing those precious
truths I hope you guys were blessed by
today's conversation if you want to look
into the light Channel some of the work
that these guys do we'll put a link in
the description below we'll also put a
link to Roger mano's video that uh that
you guys have on your Channel as well
but um keep these guys in your prayers
um you know the devil doesn't let go
easily and he's waiting for his
opportunity to just jump back in there
and try to mess things up and stuff but
we serve a powerful God if that's what
you heard out of this conversation and
um God is mighty to save and so go to
your promises sing songs use the name of
Jesus and Surrender Your Hearts
completely and utterly to Jesus and
that's this was is the recipe to to
being able to stop some of these things
um we'd love to have you leave a comment
in the section below like this video If
you um want to share this with somebody
that you think may need to have this
kind of information or be inspired for
this um also please check out our
lightwear shop we have awesome t-shirts
right here with Bible text on them and
stuff like this this is one of the ones
the designs that we have there and um
lot of great t-shirts and wear your
witness that's what it's all about right
witnessing to those around you and um
check out we've got some scripture songs
um that we have developed on a whole
another Channel as well and uh check out
those it's awesome to learn the Bible
through song we'll put a link in that
description below as well but um like
this video subscribe if you haven't
subscribed if this is your first time
here welcome we hope to see you guys
next week all
right all right I can do this
[Music]
all
right there are conventional ways of
sharing the gospel but some may need a
different way of doing things um never
mind a way that gets the message out
with
confidence wow cool shirt what's the
mean oh thank you you know we're all
made with a unique fingerprint we're all
God's artwork wow where'd you get
it lightwear wear your wig
[Music]
witness you
jaob and he for you
Isel making the pillar in the temple of
my God and he shall go out no more I
will ride on him the name of my
God strong in the Lord and in the
power Lord shall
your strength
shall shall
run I pray alone but by every word that
proceeds from the mouth of God
see
[Music]